hallo leute hier wieder einmal waren
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir die ohne
gary aus tieres reise ins zauberland ein
anime film aus dem jahre 2001 also vor
ungefähr 20 jahren feeling gulden es ist
einer der erfolgreichsten anime filme
überhaupt und ist von hayao miyazaki und
dem studio ghibli falls ihr den film
jetzt gerade nicht kennt sagt euch aber
bestimmt studio ghibli was die haben
eigentlich die schönsten anime filme
überhaupt gemacht und falsch auf dieses
video geklickt haben ohne den film
gesehen zu haben ich erzähle euch ganz
kurz die geschichte tiere und ihre
eltern sind gerade dabei umzuziehen als
sie an einem verlassenen jahrmarkt
vorbeikommen und die eltern so viel
essen das sie zu schweinen werden und
dann wird es dunkel und da kommen so
gaiser und schattenwesen und dann rennt
sie ganz schnell weg und kommt an einer
treppe an und fängt langsam an sich
aufzulösen und dann kommt da so eine art
mississippi dampfer an und steigen dann
noch mehr monster aus und sie gerät das
lied noch mehr in panik aber keine sorge
dann taucht plötzlich aus dem nichts
unser superheld hq auf und sagt zu ihr
zitat com macht den mund auf und schlug
das denn wenn sie nicht aus dieser welt
ist in der sie sich gerade befindet dann
würde sie sich komplett auflösen sie
rennen mit ungefähr 200 km/h durch
dunkle gassen und die macht muss mit hq
sein denn er schafft es die türen durch
seine gedanken zu öffnen nach diesen
ganzen stress müssen sie erstmal über
eine treppe gehen und zum badehaus
gelangen ganz normaler ruf und die liga
hat erstmal die luft anhalten damit die
monster wesen nicht merken dass ein
mensch toll war ein wesen mit so einer
weißen maske reagiert doch auf sie macht
aber nichts aber diese figur wird später
noch interessant dann kommt
entsprechender vorstellte hero bemerkt
von hug und eine dunkle seifenblase
gefangen wird und jetzt laufen sie auch
schon nicht mehr sondern fliegen
irgendwie verschwinden durch eine kleine
tür und hq bringt seine nächste super
power zum vorschein telekinese
bildübertragung durch seine hand auf
ihrer stirn sie landet dann in so einer
art heizungskeller und hängt ab da dann
ihre arbeit im badehaus an wird klingt
alles ein bisschen juli hat auch während
ich das auch geschrieben habe habe ich
gedacht so geschrieben wirkt es noch mal
anders aber der film ist wirklich
wirklich gut unter saison war die beste
leistung die ich zu diesem film geben
kann ohne zu viel zu spoilern aber euch
auch lust auf den film zu machen
aber kommen wir jetzt zu unseren unis
die uni die rics bekommt ihr hier oder
wie sie jetzt genannt wird c nachdem sie
ihre eltern im schweinestall besucht hat
und danach erst mal fix und alle
verständlicherweise unser held hqs aber
natürlich an ihrer seite und holt eine
packung mit drei unis raus und sagt dass
er es mit einem zauber belegt hat damit
sie wieder zu kräften kommt und dann
kommt die traurigste stelle überhaupt wo
sie dann anfängt zu holen und diese sony
geary ist und das ist einfach so selbst
weiß nicht ob ich schon mal in dieser
situation wartet dass ihr beim essen
weinen musste aber es ist einfach kein
guter wein und folgt so eine szene die
so richtig befreiend wirkt weil sie
endlich so richtig anfängt zu heulen
hier ist in den letzten 24 stunden so
viel schlimmes passiert das ist einfach
nur sehr schön finde zu sehen dass auch
ein hauptcharakter dann einfach mal
zusammenbricht und heult und fix und
alle mit dieser ganze scheiße und danach
wirkt sich auch sehr viel entspannter
und ich glaube das ist eine wichtige
botschaft zu lange mit der gesellschaft
so getan als ob eulen etwas schwach ist
und unangenehm ist wäre dazu muss ich
auch sagen dass männer glaube ich noch
ein bisschen mehr unter diesem problem
leiden als frauen aber grundlegend als
gesellschaft sollten wir einfach mal
zusammen mehr holen
die frage warum ich aussehe wie dreck
großmutter das können jetzt nicht klären
aber es gibt noch eine andere was sind
uni gießen igs kommen aus japan sie
werden auch nigiri machine oder ohne
schumi genannt es tut mir leid wenn ich
es jetzt falsch ausspreche ich hab noch
nie japanisch gesprochen ich lese
einfach nur vor was sind gewürzte
japanische klöße aus drei es gibt sie in
unterschiedlichen formen zum beispiel
drei oder vier eckig sowie kugelförmig
mann ist sie sowohl mit als auch ohne
füllung oder darüber gestreute
würzmischungen den klammern voreqe in
klammern was ich nicht gefunden habe in
klammern was mich sehr traurig gemacht
hat da die uni beatles bus reise ins
zauberland sehr simpel aussehen machen
wir erstmal die ohne füllung so als
einsteiger experiment und dann probieren
wir vielleicht noch mal ein paar
verschiedene füllungen aus je nachdem
was ich so hinbekommen aber ohne gierig
sollen quasi das japanische rivalen zum
butterbrot sein und wie schwer kann es
sein butterbrot schmieren
dieses mal habe ich wirklich geschafft
zu einem go ages vorzugehen letztes mal
war ich bei einem anderen und ich muss
sagen im vergleich zu denen die ich bis
jetzt kenne sind super groß
aufgeräumt gut sortiert also ich kann
euch das echt ans herz legen da mal hin
zu gehen es gibt mittlerweile in vielen
städten gescher stores und das ist jetzt
hier keine werbung also ich für mich von
großer bedeutung so und bezahlte werbung
ist das quasi jetzt nur meine erfahrung
und ich muss sagen das ist das sehr
schön ich hatte auch gehofft dass ich
eine uniform in dem laden findet gab es
aber leider nicht war ausverkauft und
dann habe ich es noch kurzzeitig bei
analysen bestellt und vielleicht kommt
sie noch in den nächsten minuten oder
stunden
ich meine wir müssen noch den reis
machen und er muss noch abkühlen also es
hat noch ein bisschen zeit aber
wahrscheinlich muss ich mit der hand
machen
es wird kommen es wird kommen und dann
fangen wir jetzt an ich habe mega bock
auf die uni gehen ich habe super tollen
hunger und falls jemand kann auch
unterstützen wollt dann vergesst nicht
zu abonnieren und einen daumen nach oben
zu geben dass unterstützt eure lieblings
creator immer sehr gut davon kriegen wir
kein geld das ist kein keine ahnung was
es gibt leute die denken dadurch daumen
hoch verdient man mehr geld
na ja auf jeden fall wird unser video
dadurch gepusht also vergesst das bitte
nicht und let's golf an wie man unserem
hauptdarsteller an sushi reis und da
habe ich sushi reis in premium-qualität
genommen ich weiß ja ob es einen
unterschied macht aber ich lasse mich
gerne von sowas beeinflussen und ich
habe 500 graben und das macht ungefähr
zwölf uni die resort und ich kann mich
zwei tage von energieried ernähren und
das ist für mich eigentlich ins gall und
wie wir in meinem letzten video gelernt
haben seinen reis muss man waschen ich
hatte dazu jetzt keine erklärung aber in
den kommentaren gab es sehr viele
verschiedene meinungen warum man es
waschen sollte sofort eine davon aus und
werdet glücklich ist ja nach der cup
methode mache ich erstmal wie viele cups
das hat
12 ungewaschen war wie ihr seht ist das
wasser jetzt extrem milchig runde drei
und vier
so wie nach 104 aus ein bisschen klar
war aber wir könnten noch klarer
hinkriegen
[Musik]
also schon wieder mit klar wie klar ist
klar dass auch ein dehnbarer begriff
oder gar nicht mehr reis freikarten
gemüse 12
das wasser sollte sohn zentimeter über
dem preis stehen und das tut er auch mit
drei kaps das kommt hin
superklasse er kommt jetzt in unseren
reiskocher hier machen wir jetzt wieder
reis gekauft
[Musik]
das ist unser wunderschöner reis er ist
natürlich noch ganz heiß auf unseren
reis machen wir jetzt so gute zwei
prisen sein und wir nehmen
reis essig und hier könnten sich jetzt
die meinungen spalten das habe ich nicht
in jedem rezept gefunden ich habe ja
viele rezepte miteinander verglichen ich
mag aber den geschmack spaß
mit ganz viel reis es sich
wahrscheinlich viel zu viel rühren wir
das jetzt einmal um
ich glaube da ist es ganz gut geworden
wir haben heute mit der beleuchtung
nicht so gut hingekriegt weil team um
ihr zu helfen
[Musik]
das ist gar nicht so viel wie ich
gedacht habe
das schaffe ich locker in zwei tagen
alleine auf zu essen natürlich braucht
man für nigeria
seetang blätter und da habe ich mich für
diese packung entschieden weil einfach
ein glas auf netflix geschaut habt eine
koreanische netflix serie über einen
typen der ein restaurant aufmacht ja
marketing hat hier bei mir funktioniert
es war für mich ganz klar dass ich diese
neue blätter nehmen und ich hab noch
spezielle nori blätter für uni diries
gefunden den kenne ich jetzt allerdings
aus keiner serie
jetzt unterwegs dann packt sein original
geriet man packt seine rigide hier auf
die packung und dann kann man das
supercup falten und du hast es gleich
eingepackt der medienmanager und er hat
mir meine uniform gebracht ich muss aber
allerdings sagen dass sie ein bisschen
kleiner wirkt als ich es mir vorgestellt
hab irgendwie habe ich an so etwas
gedacht ich meine wer zentimeter angaben
lesen kann ist ganz klar im vorteil
[Musik]
du bist mein einziges geschenk für meine
beste freundin andere interesse bekommen
pr zugeschickt ich kriege hausschuhe rät
ihr team hausschuhe was für hausschuhe
tragen schreibt gerne in die kommentare
und bleibt dieses video hq hat es ja
auch nur in so nahles
ich bin nur so abgelenkt von diesem
wunderschönen steht marco hat es ja auch
einfach in so einem stück pappe papier
deswegen lege ich mir das mal dann hier
drauf haben jetzt einfach mal unseren
ersten uniklinik den reiz darin dass man
die form immer wieder nass machen muss
macht bei der bereits glaube ich sehr
klebrig sein
und dann drücken wir einfach zu machen
auf gut aus und drücken das dann einfach
so raus
ich weiß nicht was es dort aber es ist
so zauberhaft wow
es macht schon sehen dass man nur bleibt
benutzbar es ist natürlich sehr klebrig
haben wir hier schon subway potenzial
oder würde ich sagen stellen uns der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt so
ein frisch gequetschte sony das ist
nicht geil es ist so simpel und schmeckt
leicht säuerlich und salzig ich meine
wenn ihr schon mal nigiri gegessen habt
also schießen fisch der auf dem reis
liegt dann könnt ihr euch das unbedingt
ungefähr vorstellen da hat ist ein
superschnelles und die größeres auch
perfekt
dabei holen ich kann mir jetzt füllungen
dazu so gut vorstellen ok eine vip
gurken und zucchini
es wird eine grüne füllung mit veganer
mario und nie so machen damit rein jetzt
schneide ich mein gemüse klein und
vermenge alles miteinander und die
erwähnte zucchini vergessen machen
morgen die erste runde
schale
[Musik]
machen jetzt mal was für unser land
grünen so ist
[Musik]
ob davis mit der füllung ein bisschen
übertrieben und schön in der mitte noch
machen dafür mit guacamole vorkommenden
ganz vorsichtig nur in die mitte juni
ist bestimmt auch in japan seine kunst
und braucht wahrscheinlich so 20 jahre
perfekt der uni wien meister geworden
bist das schon wieder über geknüpft ich
glaube man darf echt nicht so viel
verwenden
wenn ihr schon mal so eine gute sicht
habe packe ich gleich mal dieses ding
hier ein bett legen zuklappen hin
ich checke die anleitung nicht dann
macht man es hier auf null stellen ist
wieder der allerwichtigste frage wie
schmeckt der uni geht aus einer
allgemein gott mir nochmal sohn uri
blatt so geil bei nori blättern gibt es
immer so knick stellen wo man dann ab
das ist perfekt weil so kann man sich
das nur wie blood gute story bleibt so
kann man sich das uni gut an der hand
halten das war nicht mal deutsch
doch jetzt probiere ich einmal die
avocado füllung mit ein bisschen weniger
alge hague noch sie macht echt alles
kaputt genießbar
das ist nicht so die geschmacks
explosion die ich mir erhofft habe die
füllung kann ich euch auch extrem
empfehlen ich finde guacamole es für
nachos da nicht für nigeria es gibt auch
weitere möglichkeiten seiner uni gierig
zu befüllen ich hoffe ich konnte euch
ein bisschen inspirieren und ihr hattet
spaß beim zuschauen wenn dem so ist dann
denkt dran daumen nach oben das
unterstützt eure lieblings creator und
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten video
wieder schreibt gerne in die kommentare
was ich denn beim nächsten geschmeckt
machen soll seine bei
[Musik]